President Trump responded to Iranian
attacks on US servicemen and diplomats
last Thursday by splattering Iran's top
military official all over the Baghdad
Airport we will examine the brilliant
geopolitical strategy behind the droning
and we will attempt to explain why the
left is so upset over the death of the
world's most notorious terrorists then
speaking of killing it
ricky gervais salutely slays at the
golden globes a new poll shows
Republicans dilemma looking ahead to
2024 and the movie 1917 big Golden
Globes winner highlights a major problem
with our culture all that more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
we begin with the prospect of World War
three we finish by going all the way
back to World War one has that for
symmetry we will get to all of that and
more but first I've got to thank our
friends over at liquid IV you probably
wonder you say Michael you work all the
time how do you have so much energy
Michael you go out drinking wine and
whiskey every single night how do you
have all that energy well the answer is
liquid IV liquid IV is energy multiplier
gives you sustained energy throughout
the day you can fight fatigue without
the crash this is a great replacement
for morning coffee I know a lot of times
New Year's comes around people make a
new year's resolution to drink less
coffee not to rely on coffee all the
time
oh all those sugary processed energy
drinks and all those sort of crazy
things well liquid IV is a great
solution look what Ivy's also really
good for athletes obviously I don't know
anything about that whatsoever but I do
know that in the morning it's a great
way to get some energy and if you maybe
go out the night before with the boys
have a couple adult beverages when you
take a little liquid IV you can hydrate
yourself much much faster you can get 25
percent off when you go to liquid IV it
calm and use code knowles KO wles
at checkout that is 25 percent off
anything you order on liquid Ivy's
website just go to liquid IV dot-com and
enter promo code Knolls to save 25% and
get better hydration and energy I was
pretty skeptical of liquid IV all right
even when they came on as a sponsor so I
who incidentally ended up going to a
bachelor party as you know how those
things go sometimes and I had liquid IV
the next morning this stuff really works
it is really fantastic liquid IV dot-com
promo code Knolls KO WL e s don't wait
start fueling your adventures today
alright so you know the big news is
sulemani president Trump ordered a
strike that killed Iranians top a
military official we actually have here
at the Michael Noel's show exclusive
footage of President Trump ordering the
drone attack that killed Qasem Soleimani
what they got this shipment
what they got the whole shipment I want
that son of a I wanted dad which I want
to set out what am I alone in this world
then I asked you what your trial is over
then I asked what you turn it down
please I want you to get this where he
brings I want you to find his fancy boy
Eliot Ness I want him dead I want his
family dead
I want his house burnt to the ground I
want to go to MIT I'm not gonna Wow
harrowing footage I'm really glad that
the Daily wires investigative
journalists could get in there and and
so that we can bring that kind of
investigation to you this was a great
attack this was a really great
retaliation there is some disagreement
over this especially on the left but
even in small slivers of the
isolationist right this was a fantastic
decision by President Trump on the
foreign policy front it's probably the
best move he's made yet though he's had
other really great moves that were
unconventional unexpected unpredicted
every objection to this every objection
to this is wrong rarely our decisions so
clearly right in foreign policy and this
is one of them and I hate it the Trump
is being criticized for it because he
made a great call what was so great
about the killing of Qasem Soleimani
you need two things in foreign affairs
probably the two most important
advantages that you can have in
international relations are
unpredictability and deterrence and in
one fell swoop
president Trump reinstituted both of
those in US policy abroad
this attack was absolutely perfect in
its asymmetry
don't forget Iran has been attacking us
certainly for the entire Trump
administration and back in the Obama
administration and back into the Bush
administration this has been going on
for decades and just in the Trump
administration Iran shoots down a US
drone you remember that just a few
months ago Trump does not respond Trump
called off an attack reportedly because
he realized that an
of people were going to die and he felt
that it was not worth it to kill those
people
or to risk escalating some kind of
conflict over a drone even though is
very expensive drum them Iran launches
an attack on Saudi oil fields that was
back in September President Trump does
not respond he is not conducting a
foreign policy that is this exactly
symmetrical tit-for-tat not how it's
going to happen then Iran kills an
American contractor in Iraq and attacks
the US Embassy in Baghdad to try to
create a Benghazi situation for
President Trump and when Iran does that
Trump kills their commander-in-chief two
seconds just done that kind of asymmetry
is exactly what you want in a coherent
foreign policy sulemani was huge
now he's just sort of paint on the walls
of the Baghdad Airport but he was huge
sulemani was so big that I knew who he
was before we killed him I don't know a
whole lot of Iranian officials okay most
people don't and yet we had heard of
this guy because he was so important and
probably the most notorious terrorist in
the world certainly the most notorious
terrorists since al Baghdadi was killed
in some ways sulemani was worse though
because sulamani was a terrorist he was
directing terrorist operations he was
guiding actual full-on terrorism but he
also had a role in a nation-state which
is Iran this is this is what makes Iran
so dangerous in the world is they a
funnel terrorism right they're the
number one state sponsors of terror but
they're also a nation-state
they've had for now 40 50 years one foot
in the world order one foot outside of
the world order that's why they're so
destabilizing this sends an important
message not just to Iran not just to our
adversaries in the Middle East it sends
an important message to North Korea it
sends an important message to China it
says we're going to back up our tough
talk with action and you're never going
to be able to guess when that will
happen because you could shoot down our
very expensive drum maybe we don't do
anything you can burn down a Saudi oil
maybe we won't do anything you can take
a british ship hostage maybe we won't do
anything you can attack our embassy
maybe we'll kill your top military
official and you'll have no idea when
that will happen
you have to back up tough talk with
action sometimes that's how you keep
credibility so Trump tweeted at Iran
after the embassy attack he tweeted at
them and said cut it out guys were
pretty serious here and the Ayatollah
responded Ayatollah Khamenei said
there's nothing you can do there is
nothing you can do and that's been
Iran's strategy since the Revolution so
that's been Iran's strategy since the
70s play both sides of the World Order
keep one foot in one foot out have the
threat of global terrorism have the
threat of gaining nuclear weapons and
the whole rest of the world will back
off including the United States the most
powerful country in the history of the
world this is why it's so important not
to let Iran get nuclear weapons is
because these guys do not play by the
rules they don't play by any semblance
of the rules and so the Ayatollah says
you can't do anything Trump says yeah
we're gonna do something there are a
number of objections to president
Trump's action they are all wrong so
let's begin let's just go very quickly
through all the objections first one is
Trump is moving us closer to war with
Iran this is an objection that has some
currency on both the left and the right
Tucker Carlson on Fox News is voicing
this objection Bernie Sanders on the
Left voicing the exact same objection
here's Bernie yesterday President Trump
ordered the assassination of a top
Iranian general Qasem Soleimani in Iraq
along with the leader of an Iraqi
militia this is a dangerous escalation
that brings us closer to another
disastrous war in the Middle East which
could cost countless lives and trillions
more dollars and lead to even more
deaths more conflict
more displacement in that already highly
volatile region of the world
tucker carlson said almost exactly the
same thing on Fox and I really like
Tucker but both he and Bernie are wrong
here
they're not just wrong that this will
bring us closer to war with Iran they're
exactly wrong because this kind of
response if anything is greatly reducing
the prospect of war with Iran how is
that possible Ronald Reagan knew how
this was possible which is that you get
peace through strength you get peace
through deterrence you get peace by the
credible threat of violence that is the
way you don't get peace by rolling over
okay in just the past few weeks
Iran has killed the American contractor
attacked our embassy in Baghdad with the
guy that we just killed sulamani is
responsible for the deaths of over 600
American servicemen they took our
sailors hostage under Obama Iran started
this in war your enemies get a say you
don't get to determine whether you're at
war in part you get to determine it I
mean you get to determine your response
but your enemies who attack you get a
say and Iran has been attacking us for
years now so the question is what is
more likely to bring us closer to war
rolling over and letting them do
whatever they want and kill as many
American servicemen as they want or
responding sometimes asymmetrically
unpredictably to those attacks obviously
it is the latter Trump understands this
Ronald Reagan understood this there is
no choice between peace and war only
between fight and surrender and a
national policy of strength is much more
likely to deter future violence than a
national policy of weakness and
isolation Ronald Reagan in his most
famous speech perhaps ever the time for
choosing speech put it in precisely
those terms now let's set the record
straight
there's no argument over the choice
between peace and war but there's only
one guaranteed way you can have peace
and you can have it in the next second
surrender admittedly there's a risk in
any course we follow other than this but
every lesson of history tells us that
the greater risk lies in appeasement and
this is the specter our well-meaning
liberal friends refuse to face that
their policy of accommodation is
appeasement and it gives no choice
between peace and war only between fight
or surrender what Trump has done is
exactly Reaganesque you know there are
not perfect parallels between Trump and
Reagan they're their own men they behave
very differently they speak very
differently and yet it's it seems so
clear time and again the Trump is
learning from Reagan he's emulating
Reagan he stole Reagan's campaign theme
make America great again Reagan's theme
was let's make America great again and
Trump in his trumpian way dropped the
let's just becomes an imperative command
to make America great again but in so
many ways Trump is learning from Reagan
and nowhere is that clearer than right
here there are a number of other
objections including and this is the one
that is probably the stupidest the
objection that if you have never served
in the military if you are a civilian
then you cannot support the policy of
responding to Iranian attacks we will
get to why that one is so dumb and why
the left puts it forward all the time
first I got to thank our friends over at
Rock Auto what do I love about rock Auto
I love three things one it makes fixing
your car much easier to even somebody
who doesn't know that much about cars
like me can use Rock Auto very easily
and three it is a family business
Rock Auto has been serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years which is
pretty much the entirety of the internet
go to Rock Auto dot-com to shop for auto
and body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers they've
got everything from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps
motor oil even new carpet whether it's
for your classic or your daily driver
you can get everything you need in a few
easy clicks you'll get it delivered
directly to your door the thing about
going to an auto parts store in person
is you go there they never have the part
they just you go to the auto parts store
you say I need this part they go online
they order the part in the
they charge you a huge markup you don't
need to do that the rockauto.com catalog
is unique it is remarkably easy to
navigate even I can navigate it you get
the parts that you need for your vehicle
choose the brand specifications and
prices that you prefer they have a great
selection they've reliably low prices no
gimmicks you just get the best price
Rock Auto calm I absolutely love these
guys go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car
truck and what you have to do this is
the most important part right Knowles
Canada wles in the how did you hear
about us box so that they know we sent
you rockauto.com alright so a few more
objections to this policy the first
objection or the second objection rather
that the previous policy of appeasement
was working so well that the policy of
laying off Iran give them pallets of
cash thank them for returning our salt
or sailors rather that they take hostage
give them the path to a nuclear weapon
never do anything to upset the Iranians
we sure wouldn't want this ridiculous
country in the Middle East that was
taken through violent revolution in the
70s we wouldn't want them to be angry at
us please so that was that policy
working very well no not at all they're
attacking us everywhere they're the
largest state sponsor of terror they are
killing our servicemen hundreds of them
at a clip obviously that policy not very
good perhaps we should try new policy so
much of the Trump era was basically
saying hey those policies under Obama
many of the policies under Bush they
weren't working that well let's try
something different
well now we're trying something
different and I suspect it's gonna work
a lot better then there is the objection
you hear this from mostly from the left
occasionally from isolationists on the
right you hear if you've never served in
the military if you are a civilian then
you cannot support responding to Iran's
acts of war say yeah if you're gonna
support responding asymmetrically
occasionally to Iran's attacks of work
you need to go and list if you're a
civilian you can't have an opinion on
foreign policy that is obviously
extremely stupid why but well for one
our founding fathers thought that
argument was very stupid that's why they
gave civilians control of foreign policy
our Constitution gives civilians control
of foreign policy and it gives civilians
control of the military so you can
reject the argument right off the bat
but why does the Left make this argument
does the Left make this argument because
they're so supportive of our troops I
don't think so I remember the Iraq war
okay I remember the way the left spoke
during the Iraq war I don't believe that
it's because of their great support for
the United States military and funding
of our military and growing our military
I don't think it's that the real reason
they do it is because civilians account
for 99 percent of the population right
we live at a time right now in America
where 1% serve in the military so when
you say that if you were a civilian you
can not have an opinion on foreign
policy you immediately shut up 99% of
the population which is what the left
has been trying to do since the
beginning and they don't even really
mean it they don't even really mean that
you can't have an opinion on this
response by killing sulemani if you've
never served in the military what they
really mean is you can't support it
you're not allowed to support Trump
you're not allowed to disagree with us
the left if you are a civilian 99% of
the population not allowed to agree
disagree with us that is obviously
absurd and then the final objection
people say that Trump is starting a war
with Iran to help him politically first
of all he didn't start anything with
Iran Iran started this okay they started
this years ago and they've been ramping
up their attacks but moreover there is
no reason to think that some prolonged
conflict with Iran would help Trump
politically Americans are tired of war
specifically we're tired of war in the
Middle East so I don't know why you you
would think that this would help him
politically except that it is Right his
approval numbers are increasing since
this strike his approval numbers have
been going up why is that is that
because Americans want to conflict with
Iran no not at all it's in spite of that
I think the real reason that his numbers
are improving is the entire domestic
political angle here which is that the
left
responding in a ridiculous and absurd
way the left is defending sulemani
they're literally defending sulemani the
left is extraordinarily upset over the
killing of the world's top terrorists I
couldn't possibly wish as a right-winger
as a conservative I could not possibly
wish for a better response from the left
to this killing
when will the left get the memo that
defending terrorists who kill over 600
American servicemen is it not a great
electoral strategy I don't think they're
getting that memo because they have
Trump derangement syndrome the left is
defending sulemani I kid you not the
mainstream media kicked it off the
Washington Post referred to sulemani in
their coverage of his killing as quote a
revered military leader revered military
leader this is only slightly better than
when Trump killed the leader of Isis Abu
Bakr al-baghdadi and the Washington Post
referred to him as an austere religious
scholar world's most notorious terrorist
New York Times reporter then decided to
one-up The Washington Post by in the
wake of sulamani 'he's killing posting a
video of him reciting poetry how is that
news how is it news that the world's
worst terrorist who just got iced once
read a poem that's not news at all it
what it shows is that they have sympathy
for this guy and they have antipathy for
the American president it'd be like on
VE Day in 1945 at the end of World War
two in Europe in 1945 the big story
being pushed by the New York Times on
1945 Twitter or is Hitler's paintings
look at what a great artist he was look
at he's revered looking revered German
leader killed in a bunker for you one
look at his wonderful paintings I mean
that's basically the immediate response
to the killing of sulemani not just the
media though you've got Colin Kaepernick
who I guess at this point is just a
member of the media it's not like he's a
professional athlete or anything
he tweeted out quote America has always
sanctioned and besieged black and brown
bodies both at home and abroad America
militarism is the weapon wielded by
American imperialism to enforce its
policing and plundering of the non-white
world so what Colin Kaepernick is doing
here is making common cause with
sulemani he doesn't see himself and
sulemani is different because he's some
schmucky dumb a football player former
football player and sulemani is a
murdering terrorist no he sees them as
similar because they have a similar skin
color that's recent
he's saying America is sanctioning and
besieging black and brown bodies both at
home and abroad it's it's the same thing
the horrible oppression that I Colin
Kaepernick have felt I multimillionaire
Colin Kaepernick who's made more money
since I protested the American flag in
the NFL than I ever made actually
playing football but that kind of
oppression that I feel is exactly the
same kind of oppression that that poor
old kasym sulamani felt obviously a very
very stupid idea this is what ideology
does to your brain this is what racial
identity politics does your brain is it
causes you to make common cause with
terrorists wasn't just Kaepernick though
AOC was so angry she was soap said she
accused Trump of war crimes for killing
a terrorist by the way just again I want
to reiterate I make this point every so
often every time this objection comes up
killing terrorists it's not a war crime
it's not a violation of the Geneva
Convention torturing terrorists not a
violation of the Geneva Convention if
anything it is a support of the Geneva
Convention the Geneva Convention
protections all of the kind of
protections we have for lawful
combatants in war explicitly exclude
terrorists
why because the whole purpose of the
Geneva Convention is to protect
civilians in time of war but terrorists
don't
protect civilians they target civilians
guys like sulemani who played both sides
of it the nation-state side the lawful
combatant uniformed soldier in a time of
war side and the funding terrorism
everywhere side are targeting civilians
and so if you extend those kind of
protections to people who target
civilians you undermine the entire
purpose of those protections I would not
expect AOC to know that and she doesn't
so I know she watches this show listens
to this show now you understand Ilhan
Omar same thing she was outraged that's
the word that Ilhan Omar used to
describe the killing of the world's top
terrorists and then by far the craziest
one Rose McGowan who is an actress I
take it she became very popular during
the me2 movement as one of the me2
victims she tweeted out with a bizarre
Jif of the Iranian flag that had a
couple emojis on it she tweeted out
quote dear Iran the USA has disrespected
your country your flag your people 52%
of us humbly apologize we want peace
with your nation we are being held
hostage by a terrorist regime we do not
know how to escape please do not kill us
hashtag
sulemani this is what the left believes
okay this is what the left believes
they're upset when you disrespect the
flag of Iran of the mullahs in Iran and
they celebrate when you disrespect the
flag of the United States of America
during NFL games she believes this is
what the left believes that 52% of
Americans apologize to Iran we should
just killed American citizens just
killed American contractors just killed
American servicemen tried to attack our
embassy that 52 the majority of
Americans support Iran and a post Donald
Trump that's what they believe Rose
McGowan has since apologized but I think
it was just a I hate to question her
motives I suspect she still believes
those things I think it was an apology
of convenience the Trump derangement
syndrome is so bad the left is now
defending Iranian terrorists
killed hundreds of Americans this has
almost become comical all right Trump
has done this for years now he trolled
the Democrats into opposing the American
flag and mourning for terrorists Ted
Cruz right now in the Senate is
introducing a resolution to praise the
sulemani mission why is he doing this it
should be obvious a hundred percent of
senators should support this resolution
but they won't he's putting them in a
very tight bind because by praising the
mission they have to support Donald
Trump and they hate Trump so much that
they're gonna defend sulemani that aside
all of that aside this was a really
great move puts Iran in a terrible
position now Iran is going to retaliate
but how can they how are they how are
they going to really be able to
retaliate
they've already been attacking us
steadily for years and increasingly and
they obviously wanted to ramp this up
during an election year there were going
to be more attacks
sulemani was planning more attacks
reportedly so how are they going to
respond now previously they knew that
the u.s. wasn't going to do anything
because we were so afraid of any further
conflict with Iran then Trump kills
their top military official so how are
they going to respond maybe they'll
attack Israel
maybe they'll try to attack an American
base if they plan anything really big
though they're they're in a position now
where the US could glass their country
practically I mean they could glass the
political leadership of the country the
mullahs Trump tweeted this out he said
Iran is talking very boldly about
targeting certain USA assets as revenge
for ridding the world of their terrorist
leader who had just killed an American
and badly wounded many others not to
mention all the people he'd killed over
his lifetime including recently hundreds
of Iranian protesters he was already
attacking our embassy in preparing for
additional hits in other locations Iran
has been nothing but problems for many
years let this serve as a warning that
if Iran strikes any Americans or
American assets we have targeted 52
Iranian sites representing the 52
American hostages taken by Iran many
years ago some at a very high level and
important to Iran in the Iranian culture
and those targets and Iran itself all
caps classic Trump will be hit very fast
and very hard the USA wants no more
threats why do I trust this guy to
conduct foreign policy well as of today
he's the only president
not to start a war since 1988 Trump
shares equality with Reagan which is
talking tough they talk tough
differently but they both talk tough
Ronald Reagan was asked his theory on
the Cold War after decades of date and
Ronald Reagan said here's my theory on
the Cold War we win they lose Ronald
Reagan one time was doing a mic test on
the radio and he said I've just signed a
law that will permanently abolish the
Soviet Union the bombing begins in five
minutes this was a joke but that went on
high alert
all right Ronald Reagan talk tough they
called him a cowboy he knew Trump knows
that the way to prevent war is to be
unpredictable and credible in the use of
force Trump just did it my hat goes off
to him but sulemani was not the most
brutal attack of the weekend not not by
a long shot
actually even more brutal than Trump's
droning of Qasem Soleimani were Ricky
Gervais cease attacks on Hollywood at
the Golden Globes they were absolutely
magnificent we will get to them in just
a second then we will get to what what
all of this means for 2024 not just 2020
but looking ahead to 2024 and finally we
go all the way from World War 3 to World
War 1 to discuss 1917 won big at the
Golden Globes and it expresses something
very broken in our culture we'll get all
that in a bit but first I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube head on
over to daily wired.com you know you can
subscribe you getting me you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Andrew Klavan
sure you get the man wall show it has
questions in the mailbag you get another
Kingdom you get the leftist ears tumblr
you get it all but you've got to go to
daily wire.com head on over we'll be
right back
far more cold-blooded far more brutal
than the killing of sulamani were ricky
gervais sis attacks on Hollywood last
night at the Golden Globes the Golden
Globes
opening up awards season here in
Hollywood award season is so irrelevant
these days that I didn't even know what
was happening I'd forgot I have worked
professionally in show business I live
in Hollywood I am right here at the
center of it and I forgot that it was
going on I didn't know until yesterday
when someone said oh you know the Golden
Globes song really okay who cares
that is how out of touch these people
are they decided to become relevant this
year that the Golden Globes was going to
go vegan so they served dinner at this
particular awards show and there was
gonna go completely vegan to help the
environment because that's that's the
way that they're gonna finally turn
their failing ratings around and relate
to the American people no probably not
so Ricky Gervais gets up there he's
hosted this a number of times in the
past he said this would be his last time
hosting and Ricky Gervais sidon care he
went for the necks of Hollywood and he
wow I just realized the pun there
because he opened up the night with an
Epstein joke so fun was not intended but
there but all of Ricky Gervais sees
attacks were intended he said I don't
care I'm leaving nothing on the table
and I think his monologue was pretty
much the only shot that the awards
season has to relate in any way to the
American people it was great and it was
great at the expense of the audience in
the room the Hollywood stars the
Hollywood Foreign Press Association he
opens the night with a joke about
Jeffrey Epstein
spoiler alert season two is on the way
so in the end he obviously didn't kill
himself just like Jeffrey Epstein
shut up I know he's your friend but I
don't care you got to make your own way
air in your own plane didn't ya oh my
gosh what a great one too he opens up
with the Jeffrey Epstein joke right that
would have been enough but Hollywood
can't laugh about Jeffrey Epstein they
didn't laugh they kind of stayed a
little quiet they kind of groaned which
set up Gervase for the actual punchline
of his joke which is oh shut up I know
you're all friends with the guy because
they are they are all friends with the
guy and they're all friends with all the
meet two perpetrators and they're
friends with all of these sex criminals
and they pretend that they're not only
they clutch their pearls and they
pretend to be so nice and wonderful in
high and mighty he says yeah you had to
take your own plane here tonight didn't
you
that one finally got the lights so
awkward it was so brutal and the attacks
only got harsher from there he went
after every single person in that room
for hypocrisy and many points you could
pretty much hear a pin drop
a superb drama about the importance of
dignity and doing the right thing made
by a company that runs sweatshops in
China so will you say you woke but the
companies you work for I mean
unbelievable
Apple Amazon Disney if Isis started a
streaming service you'd call your agent
wouldn't you so if you do win an award
tonight please don't use it as a
platform to make a political speech
right you're in no position to lecture
the public about anything you know
nothing about the real world most of you
spent less time in school than Greta
Thumb Berg so if you win right come up
accept Julianne Ward fate your agent and
your God
that little bit that we had to bleep out
there at the end is where ricky gervais
told people where they could go after
they had received their award it was a
wonderful spectacle it was great
ricky gervais Sasan international
treasure why because he showed the gap
between Hollywood and the American
people he showed the gap between the
Hollywood Foreign Press the
international press the big makers of
culture and the consumers of culture and
you can't deny that gap because these
awards shows have been tanking in the
ratings for years now every single year
Hollywood cannot even laugh at an
Epstein joke a joke about an
international sex trafficking criminal
pedophile everything everything about
the guy they can't laugh at it because
they knew him because they were friends
with him they don't understand now the
more interesting level of analysis here
is whether or not Ricky Gervais was
brave to do this set and the
conventional wisdom is it was so brave
of Ricky Gervais Stu do this set in
front of Hollywood now in many ways it
was because this will hurt his
employment prospects of Hollywood he was
telling these people that they're
degenerates to their face right it was
absolutely hilarious and in that way it
was courageous to do it but in another
sense it wasn't brave at all because
Ricky Gervais snoo because he's a funny
comedian he knew that the audience would
love this that they would laugh this up
that they would say finally Ricky
Gervais this guy is so good this guy
gets us he deserves credit because it
really will irritate his his employers
but this will make him so much more
popular among the audience the only
reason that any person is talking about
the Golden Globes today is because Ricky
Gervais had this great killer set and
looking ahead on the political scene to
2020 it shows you how absolutely
worthless celebrity endorsements are the
left are always shocked they say Oh
Hillary Clinton got all the endorsements
of Hollywood all these
big time movie stars and TV stars how
did she lose John Kerry got all the big
endorsements Bruce Springsteen Puff
Daddy all these guys how did they lose
because none of us like Hollywood we
don't like these people for the ones
that are good performers and there are
still good performers in Hollywood even
if they're left wing lunatics we like
watching them perform and then we want
them to shut up because we don't care
what they think about politics a couple
of them have interesting thoughts about
politics a couple of them are very
intelligent and actually know what
they're talking about James Woods is a
good example James Woods great Hollywood
star terrific actor also very very
intelligent man but most actors are not
intelligent some are some are not Ronald
Reagan pretty pretty intelligent guy
obviously won the Cold War
knew something about politics most do
not and so for most of them most of
these absolutely empty-headed
celebrities we want them to go out there
and perform we like them when they do
that we don't like them when they Yammer
on about politics and use the
opportunity of accepting golden statues
to harangue all of us about how awful we
are and have virtuous and wonderful they
are we don't like it celebrities
nevertheless ignored the advice Michele
Williams in particular goes out there
Michelle Williams accepts the Golden
Globe and she uses the opportunity in a
follow-up to Patricia Arquette a few
years ago at the Oscars to make a
statement about women voting but it was
a very unclear statement she said women
need to vote in their self-interest
whatever that means women 18 to 118 when
it is time to vote
please do so in your own self-interest
it's what men have been doing for years
it's what men have been doing for years
which is why the world looks so much
like them but don't forget we are the
largest voting body in this country
let's make it look more like us the
world looks like men not from my vantage
because most people on earth are women
so it looks like women I guess what does
that mean that doesn't mean anything and
she knows it doesn't mean she's kind of
working through the incoherence as she's
giving the speech
so she says women are the largest voting
bloc in this country so how come they're
not how come they're not voting for far
leftist policies they need to vote in
their own interests that's why would
they are voting in their own interest
how condescending how offensive to say
that women are just too stupid except
for Hollywood celebrities well the
average American woman according to
Michelle Williams is a complete idiot
but the average Hollywood celebrity is
really smart that's the only way that
you can explain why the average American
woman doesn't vote the way that the
average Hollywood celebrity wants them
to vote but she's not really talking
about women she's talking about
Hollywood liberals it's the same thing
Colin Kaepernick's doing when he makes
common cause with terrorists he said he
but Colin Kaepernick is saying in his
tweet that black and brown people need
to have solidarity with Iranian
terrorists that that's that's the real
solidarity but he's he isn't talking
about black or brown voting identity
groups he's talking about radical
leftist voting identity groups same
thing here Michele Williams is not
talking about the group solidarity of
women she's talking about the group
solidarity of Hollywood liberals and
she's pretending that that means women
this was a veering and bizarre speech if
you don't really know what she's talking
about when it comes to this woman's self
interest issue until you realize that
she's talking about abortion
in particular and what's so perverse
about this is that as Michelle Williams
give this gives a speech that comes to
just be a big full-throated endorsement
of abortion she's pregnant
well she gives it grateful for the
acknowledgement of the choices I've made
and I'm also grateful to have lived at a
moment in our society where choice
exists because as women and as girls
things can happen to our bodies that are
not our choice I've tried my very best
to live a life of my own making not just
a series of events that happened to me
but one that I could stand back and look
at and recognize my handwriting all over
sometimes messy and scrawling sometimes
careful and precise
but one that I had carved with my own
hand and I wouldn't have been able to do
this without employing a woman's right
to choose okay I suspect what this means
is that she has had an abortion that's
what she said she said I couldn't have
the career that I want and I couldn't be
really famous and rich if I hadn't
killed my child maybe that's true maybe
she would be less rich and less famous
if she had not killed her child what
makes this so heartbreaking what makes
this so bizarre to the audience is that
she's currently pregnant and so on the
one hand she's saying we need to support
abortion we need to support killing
babies I'm not gonna kill my precious
baby but all you poor people should kill
your babies because you're not rich and
famous yet and then you kill your babies
and you get rich and famous you
sacrifice your children on the altar of
career and money and Mammon and then you
become rich and famous and then you
don't have to kill your babies anymore
then you can keep them that's what she's
saying
Ryan she's saying rich people don't have
to poor people should do that that's
very incoherent why is it okay to kill
your bait some babies but not other
babies why is it okay to kill your
babies sometimes but not other times
it's not and that's why the speech
doesn't make any sense and she just
keeps going back to bumper stickers like
a woman's right to choose my choice I
make my own decisions bumper stickers
are always wrong right slow these kind
of slogans that are distillation of
ideology are always wrong and this is a
prime example of that but it's pretty
horrifying when you see the reality of
it and that's why Ricky Gervais is so
successful last night when you present
to the American people Michelle will
pregnant Michelle Williams talking about
how it's really important to kill your
baby if you want to get money and fame
and ricky gervais hsihu saying you
people are DeGeneres guess which one the
American people are going to go for
obviously Ricky Gervais snow back to
politics in just our last few minutes
here we've talked about the 2020
Democrats enough there's no real
front-runner here Bernie Sanders is
bringing in the most money at the moment
Liz Warren
totally losing momentum a new poll
Ephrem from Hill Harris X polling she
was that Liz Warren has now dropped down
to be tied with Mike Bloomberg at 11
percent nationally that is pathetic she
was the front-runner just recently a
Buddha judge is sort of surging but he's
only popular among white yuppies on the
coasts so that's probably not gonna take
him very far and Joe Biden can't
remember his own name so things are not
looking great on the Democratic side
there there's just nobody right there's
no clear candidate there's no clear
front-runner however it's also important
to point out other than Donald Trump
there's nobody really on the Republican
side either there's a new poll out from
SurveyMonkey and Axios about the 2024
field that's way too early to predict
what's gonna happen in 2024 but what the
poll tells us is something important
about right now the poll shows that
among the top contenders in 2024 among
Republicans being polled or the Trump
family Don junior and Ivanka Trump you
got pence at 40% he's leading especially
with older voters Don junior is the
clear choice among younger voters and
he's got 29 percent overall then nikki
Haley at 26% many Ivanka Trump at 16%
then Rubio and Pompeyo what this tells
us is that the GOP wants an heir to
Trump and to trumpism they don't want to
go back to the way that it used to be
they like Trump Trump has 95 percent
approval in the GOP right now so they
want an heir to Trump there is no clear
heir to trump and so they are literally
choosing the heir to trump which is
Donald Trump jr. nothing against Don jr.
or Ivanka they seem like very nice
people but they have not had a political
life outside of being a Trump so you
can't really judge them on the merits of
their own political life we don't really
know what they believe or what they
would do the reason that they're so high
in the polls right now is because the
GOP needs an heir to Trump and it does
not appear that there is one just yet a
political heir and so that's going to
have to be a major priority of
conservatives over the next four years
assuming president Trump gets reelected
they're going to
figure out who comes next who fits the
mold of Trump that's an open question
right now finally before we go there was
a big surprise last night at the Golden
Globes beyond the Ricky Gervais stuff
which was that the movie 19:17 won Best
Drama 1917 is this this very long movie
about World War one I saw it over the
weekend it's not a very good movie but
it is worth seeing which I think
explains the weird Rotten Tomatoes
reviews the movies got 90% critics
review 95% audience review so very very
high and yet it's not a good movie and
yet I still liked seeing it what does
that mean it was directed co-written and
produced by Sam Mendes stars George
McKay who gave a superb performance in
it the problem with the movie is it's
not really about anything I can't tell
you what it's about I sat through 202
hours at least of the movie I don't know
what the story is the movie is more a
video game than a movie it's got these
beautiful shots it's got these amazing
moments you follow this guy like you
would follow the protagonist in a video
game and and you pretty much never leave
him it's well acted it's mostly
enjoyable pretty much enjoyable the
whole time but it's not a movie it
doesn't really have a purpose beyond
showing how skillfully produced it was
it doesn't say anything it doesn't
really convey any meaning it's just
really beautifully shot and keeps your
attention because it's kind of like
moving through a video game but there's
no narrative this is a major problem in
the culture not just for the movies the
movies which have pretty much lost their
purpose and have become entirely self
referential think about the rise of
Quentin Tarantino who only makes movies
about movies think about all these
awards shows which are just about the
movie industry which are just about how
wonderful everyone in movies is it
doesn't convey a narrative that we have
lost the narrative as a culture we've
lost the ability to understand narrative
we've lost faith in their ative we've
lost
and the idea that life really does have
meaning that there really isn't purpose
to things there really is a purpose to
our own lives we've lost like the the
idiom that you would use is we've lost
the narrative it's no surprise that 1917
won an award I sort of thought that it
might even though it's not a great movie
it's not so a surprise that we're
confused over whether this is good or
not what it means we're very confused as
a culture the key is going to be
retaking the narrative reclaiming a
sense of objective reality reclaiming a
sense of purpose that is a cultural
problem that is a political problem it
looks like right now the political side
is leading things these people not just
in the United States but around the
Western world reclaiming their purpose
reclaiming their meaning as nations the
culture is now going to have to follow
suit it's a little bit of an inversion
of that andrew breitbart idea that
politics is downstream of culture but of
course the line between the two is
pretty blurry they go back and forth
pretty often the culture is going to
have to follow suit hopefully they get
the message from Ricky Gervais and all
the rest of us and and they do that
because we need to reclaim the narrative
all right that's our show I'm Michel
Knowles this is the Michael Dahl show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
assistant director havel we douse key
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and make-up Jeshua alvera production
assistant McKenna waters the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh oh we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation